you retrain your brain one small  decision at a time it's one small step  at a time this is where so many people  fail and fall down as you think that  retraining your brain is making just one  decision one giant decision and now i'm  not going to be this person anymore and  then what happens is you become that  person again and then you let yourself  down you stop trying to say it's never  going to happen for me i'm just this  kind of person and i'm just going to  accept it where the retraining is one  step at a time  it's one single decision at a time and  every time you do it every time you say  yes every time you notice that that  thing is going to happen again and then  you make a chip you make a change you  start to change your identity and  retrain your brain